hey you guys
time for another flickers of fear my
horror movie review show so this movie
i'm going to be talking about today this
is one that i kept seeing it was just
kept getting all this buzz and it kept
coming up on these you know best horror
movies of 2020 lists
and so finally i think probably like a
week or two before i'm recording this
hulu added it so i was like oh so i
added it to the list
to uh to review and i finally ended up
watching it this week this is called she
dies
tomorrow now this film i think it was
supposed to premiere at the south by
southwest festival
but obviously that got delayed or
cancelled or whatever because of
kovid so it ended up getting picked up
by
neon and uh it ran in some drive-in
theaters so it had like a limited sort
of theatrical release
but then it came to vod um the end of
july so
basically this is a story okay so it's
written and directed
by amy siemens i hope i've seen it
summits i hope i'm pronouncing that
right
uh she's actually she was a very she's a
very recognizable actress but she's also
a writer and director
she's been in like a ton of indie stuff
i think she's on the hbo show the
killing
um she was in alien covenant and she was
also
in pet cemetery like the remake in 2019
she had directed some short films and
she also did one called sun don't shine
in 2012 which i haven't seen but i have
heard a little bit about it
so basically this is kind of her second
feature film that she's directing
now i don't know this this is for sure
a psychological horror film uh
i would even call it maybe a
philosophical horror film it has a very
strange
like almost meditative
kind of vibe to it and it has like i
mean the cinematography is really cool
and it's just really
i don't know there's something about
like the tone and the mood of it that's
really appealing
that said if you're not really into more
philosophical more slow burn more
metaphorical type horror then probably
this is not for you
um it really does seem like a lot of
critics seem to really dig it it seemed
to have like you know
80 90 uh you know on rotten tomatoes and
whatnot
but audience score is a lot more divided
and i can kind of see why
um i will say i liked this movie but
i didn't love it i kind of feel like
i kind of got what it was saying but i
feel like it maybe belabored the point a
little bit
um and it's not very long it's only like
an hour and 25 minutes something like
that
it seemed actually kind of a lot longer
than it was but like i said there's a
lot of things to
recommend it also but just know going
into it this is not an action movie by
any means it's very
slow paced it's very languid um and it's
very there's not
a ton of dialogue either and also
there's not really
there's not really like a main
protagonist but
it does have kind of a little bit of a
plot sort of so i'll kind of get into
that
so basically the story starts out
there's this young woman
named amy and all we know about her
is that she has just bought a house but
she seems really bummed out about it
like she seems really
kind of out of it like she doesn't care
and she's just like yeah whatever
you know you know what i mean she's kind
of like that now
at the beginning she's talking to a
friend of hers
on the phone you don't really know how
they're friends or anything like that
but she's talking to this friend named
jane
and jane initially seems like really
worried about her because she's like man
you sound really kind of out of it are
you depressed are you okay
it kind of comes through it's kind of
implied uh later on that amy is
a recovering alcoholic or some type of
addict i assumed it was an alcoholic
and um maybe jane is afraid that she's
having a relapse again
so jane is kind of like well you know i
i need to come over there because you
sound like you're having some problems
but
i told my brother that i would go to
this birthday party for his
wife even though she hates me and i hate
her and it's all this it's this big
thing
so after she hangs up with jane she
starts just kind of hanging out in her
house
behaving very strangely she's just kind
of like laying on the floor
like caressing the wood she starts
drinking a [ __ ] ton
she starts playing uh mozart's i think
it's lacrimosa
like just over and over and over again
like she on her record player
and she's acting very very strange and
sometimes there's like some weird visual
cues too where it's like a flashing
red lights flashing blue lights things
of that nature and then she starts doing
these weird
searches on her laptop like she's
searching for funeral urns
and then she's searching for leather
jackets for some reason
so so you have this kind of whole thing
going on and that kind of goes on for
um you know kind of a long time and then
jane does actually come over there
at which point amy seems like she seems
very very drunk and she also
seems very very depressed and she keeps
saying that she's going to die tomorrow
and that if she dies you know she's
actually very sure that she's going to
die tomorrow so she tells jane will you
make sure
because i really want after i die i want
a leather jacket to be made out of my
skin
so i can be something useful so she's
saying things like that so jane
is you know understandably quite alarmed
by this but
jane is or rather amy is insistent that
she's going to die tomorrow
now interestingly what happens from here
is that the focus kind of shifts off of
amy to this point and goes on to jane
now even though jane had originally like
she was kind of gonna go to this
birthday party but she wasn't jazzed
about it because she's like look it's my
sister-in-law and i hate her
we you know we hate each other and it's
going to be awkward so she had kind of
blown it off
but then later she decides that she
doesn't want to be alone so she goes to
the party now she shows up at this party
and she's all like disheveled and she
has like pajamas on and [ __ ] like that
and then she starts saying
that she is certain that she is gonna
die tomorrow also
so basically that's how the rest of the
movie plays out it's almost kind of like
this
idea that you're going to die tomorrow
is sort of like a mind virus
and you can pass it from one person to
another because jane shows up at this
part it's not like a huge party it's
just like four or five people or
whatever
and um starts talking about how she's
gonna die tomorrow
and it essentially infects like the
other people at the party like the
brother the wife and like two of their
friends who were there
and then we kind of follow them as they
kind of go about their lives and
you know what that means so so it's very
very weird it's this kind of like
episodic following of each character
as each character becomes infected with
this idea
that they're going to die tomorrow and
that's
basically all that happens in this movie
so the movie it's like
in a way it's saying a lot about i think
that amy seemetz like has said that she
got the idea for the script for this
by when she was telling people about
anxiety attacks or panic attacks and how
people would react to that
and it's a really really interesting
idea that
fear is contagious and i like the fact
too that they kind of have this whole
thing about
death and it's just it's weird how it
worms its way into
different people's uh thoughts because
you know when jane comes to the party
and starts talking about i'm gonna die
tomorrow and she was certain about it
and at first
everybody's just kind of like whatever
you know she's kind of nuts
but then some of the other party guests
were like you know
it's possible it's like you you know you
gotta die sometime
it's like why wouldn't it be tomorrow
you know what i mean and then from then
it just keeps like the infection keeps
spreading
so you kind of follow that around and
then at the end there's like a little
bit
of a flashback where you kind of find
out
that amy the original girl that was
saying that she was going to die
tomorrow
she apparently got it from her boyfriend
craig
when they were at this they had kind of
done like a romantic getaway type thing
or whatever
and uh at this cabin and i guess
everything had been normal but then they
ordered a pizza
and you you are led to believe that
craig was infected by it like by the
pizza guy like when
you don't see the pizza guy but you just
see like craig's back
then when he comes back to the table
he's acting like really weird and like
depressed and stuff
so you don't really know so so it's a
very ambiguous film
in the sense that you don't really know
where this virus came from
you don't really know you know and this
is maybe a spoiler i guess even though a
movie like this it doesn't really matter
i suppose but um you never find out
if the people actually that said they
were gonna die tomorrow if they actually
do die tomorrow the only person that you
know for sure does
is craig because they kind of when they
do the flashback like he killed himself
you're led to believe or amy might have
killed him they don't really specify
that either
and they so they don't really tell you
but like i said it's kind of like a
philosophical or like a meditation
on if you knew for sure that you were
gonna die tomorrow like what would you
do like with the end of your life and
everything
that said i love the idea of it i love
the idea
of fear and death like as an infection
and like it can be passed from person to
person just by someone talking about it
and like i said it's it's kind of like
an interesting idea of how fear can just
spread throughout a community like very
quickly just
through words i liked that idea um but i
do kind of feel like the movie
was a little bit i mean it seemed like
it was a little bit repetitive like you
kind of knew where it didn't like have a
three-act structure didn't i'm not
saying that movies have to
have that i'm just saying that once you
got
the gist of it i you know i feel like it
just was kind of like more of that you
know what i mean so it was just like
following characters around
um you know as they were like oh i'm
gonna die tomorrow you know what i mean
so and it manifested itself in slightly
different ways like with each person
but not different enough that i think it
kind of
merited a full-length movie i guess i
think this probably would have made a
better short film
because i really did like the
philosophical questions that it
uh you know posited so i liked that kind
of thing and i even liked kind of the
ambiguity like you never really knew
like
if most of the people that thought they
were going to die tomorrow actually did
die tomorrow
like you didn't know if it was like you
know is a media are going to hit the
earth or some [ __ ] like that
and i was watching um someone else had
done like a
a breakdown of this and there was
actually like a lot of really
interesting like symbolism and sort of
easter eggs and stuff like that that was
going on in the background
that i kind of maybe didn't pick up on a
lot of it so that did give me a lot more
appreciation for it
but overall i don't know um i didn't
find it like super super compelling like
i've
found it compelling enough to watch it
to the end but i thought it was a little
bit slow a little bit languid
and i just felt like it kind of
belabored its point a little bit um
that's all but as i said overall it's a
decent move if you like art flicks
it's visually beautiful the acting's
amazing
um so it has like some weird like black
humor in it as well like a little bit of
a black comedy kind of aspect to it no i
don't want to oversell that because it's
pretty subtle
but it does have a little bit of that in
it but just if you know what you're
getting into
it's you know it's a decent flick but
it's like i said it's
way more psychological horror very
subdued but you know
it's on hulu at the moment at least in
the united states and when this is being
recorded
so uh if you'd like to check it out for
yourself then by all means do so and let
me know in the comments what you thought
about it
and that'll do it for this flickers of
fear and i will see you on the next one
bye